[Music]
hello welcome to the pretty intense
podcast a treat today we have a race car
driver on the show Denny Hamlin it's
funny I asked a bunch of people to send
in their questions and of course many of
them said why did he crash you so much
of course I asked that he's a fantastic
driver he has 48 wins he started in the
Cup Series in 2005. he has yet to get
that elusive Championship but I tell you
what as for as long as I can remember
he's in the mix every year at the end of
the season for the championship at the
last race he's incredible he's a good
friend yes he crashed me a whole bunch
in a short span of time but uh we
totally talked about that we talked
about the sport we talked about
relationships I didn't think we'd go
there but we kind of launch off in that
space we talk about the sport and where
it's going and where it's been and just
like what does it need and we talk about
life and just kind of the things that he
wants to do enjoy the show please hit
subscribe I really appreciate when you
do and you show the support I love to do
this show so by subscribing and watching
the show you're supporting that mission
of planting seeds and sharing
information and as I say in the intro
walking each other home so enjoy the
show so I'm just gonna pick up where we
left off which was uh asking if you
wanted to go to Burning Man with me
someday because other drivers have
definitely like I was sitting in line
getting out it's called The Exodus at 9
00 pm and I didn't get out of it until
10 sorry 7 A.M it was 10 hours and I'm
like
bucket I'm just gonna like post a bunch
of stuff on Instagram and I had like
messages coming in from people at like 3
A.M which was six six something a.m on
the east coast and they're all like oh
my God how was it so are you in I mean
yeah I I think that uh it would
certainly be a different experience for
me
um you know it seems like the hours of
operation there are a little different
from what the the normal uh hours in
which I would sleep which would be
awesome uh it seems like it's is it in
the middle of nowhere yeah absolutely I
thought you were a night owl you're not
a night owl
I've partied enough for many uh
lifetimes but uh you know now that I've
got a couple kids it's just uh things
are different now you know it's just uh
my days start earlier I have meetings
every single day that start earlier and
uh yeah I just by the time I get you
know the kids put to bed or we get the
kids put to bed it's it's done time for
me it is different you go to bed at
about
six seven eight a.m like you a lot of
times people want to watch the sunrise
um I saw it a few times I saw the full
Sunrise once and then you sleep for a
few hours like three or four hours was
usually what I averaged and then you
just kind of get up it's also hot AF in
that trailer that I rented because trust
me you don't want to take your bus
because it's like a complete mess it
gets it gets inside the bus even with
the doors and windows shut it's just it
can't help it it finds a way and a lot
of people are they tempting out there I
mean just all kinds of different
accommodations whatever you choose to
stay and this for how many days
well I was there for about a week
oh wow I know when I was talking to my
friend who went with me nada I was like
so how long should we go like three or
four days or something she's like
um
you kind of go for the week and I was
like oh [ __ ] this is serious so you just
have to like to really submit to being
dirty
and you're fine with that I've I've
witnessed you're fine with that wait I'm
with three in one with nature and
whatever surrounded around you I'm not
saying that's a good thing you adapt to
your your environment you're like a
lizard
wow I'm so glad I'm going to ask you the
next question in my mind after we get
done with this topic
um yeah it's cool it's really cool but
it's like I've never seen anything like
it because it's all it's like total
truth that's what it feels like if you
want to be naked
you're naked like there's this one thing
that you can go do called the human Car
Wash human Car Wash Dr Bronner's is this
company that has a camp and so that's
who puts it on and you wait in line and
you and you get in and almost everyone's
goes completely naked and like a like
yeah like a automated here's my turn to
get
you get hosed down
with the soap then I think that you can
I think there's help possibly I'm not
sure I didn't do it I was almost gonna
do it but it was a whiteout the last day
that they were open and then you get
rinsed off and then there's a dance
floor down below
where you dry off
I'd have to get really comfortable with
myself
I tell you what there are a lot of
really comfortable people there that's
all I'm gonna say or if you want to be
totally closed if you want to like you
know if you want to go to the temple and
cry and you know mourn somebody like
there was a lot of memorials for people
um that's what the temple is for
um you know there's just like basically
whatever you want whatever you want
anything you want
I just I just got done watching the uh
Woodstock 99 on Netflix and I'm like
wow so it seems like what you're
describing has got a mix of that but a
lot more
spiritual I guess
yeah yeah yeah probably
um I mean I haven't seen that but
there's definitely
um there's definitely some intention to
it like the spiritual intentional part
of it and I know that you've like
slipped a little bit into spiritualness
a little bit yeah you know it's it's as
you get older you start
thinking about the why and so for me
it's that's changed over the years and
so you know you're trying to you know
figure out what is the greater purpose
of all this you know I've achieved
everything that I ever would have
imagined
how can I what what's next what you know
what is next for me what is the greater
goal in all of this so it's just uh it's
interesting I never would have thought
I'd be at this point of my life where I
see things through the perspective that
I do see them oh tell me more like
thoughts like so what are some things
that surprise you that you think of now
or that you want to do yeah I mean like
go naked in the human Car Wash like are
you surprised that you want to do that
uh no nothing surprises me especially
with the way that my mind works no
um but yeah I just think that uh I never
really understood until you have kids
that people are saying you know you
still have fun but the kind of fun that
you have is different you know uh when I
was much younger you know it was very
tough coming into the Nascar Cup Series
when I came in because I I came through
like a bullet like I went from working
at my dad's trailer shop making 10 bucks
an hour to running in the cup series
making millions in about 16 months like
that was it so I just uh really had a
tough time with that transition of like
going from a normal everyday job
um to then be in vaulted into I'm in the
Limelight uh um I'm popular I'm
successful in this in this field and how
do I
um how do I bring that all in and it and
listen that takes its toll on on a lot
of different things to learn
relationships it takes the toll on your
friends that are back at home hey you
left us you forget us and you know so
you get pulled in so many directions I
don't know that you know really I did it
the the right way for the first five to
six years of my career what did you do
that you would have done different I've
always been close with my friends I
actually brought two of my high school
friends down and lived with me uh but
you know I just think that I didn't
treat my relationships fairly
um early friendships or relationship
like relationships yeah Intimate
Relationships yeah just because
um you know I got kind of full of myself
at you know during a certain period just
that you know I was I was successful I
just really it's one thing to make it to
to NASCAR's top level then be successful
in my early 20s mid-20s like you know I
wanted to live it up I wanted to be like
Dale Jr and when he was having parties
on uh you know Tuesday night or Thursday
night Clubby
yeah something like that I was just
coming into it when he was starting to
have that and he just started his Saloon
his old you know old time Saloon back by
his house I'm like well I'm gonna put on
parties too and challenge his parties
and so you know you know it just that
was kind of what happened and so we
would go to the local uh bar up here
called The Rusty Rudder on the lake and
I remember we would just take every
Tuesday night we would go there and I'd
have friends we'd come play cards at my
house for an hour or two and then we
would go and uh go to the bar at the
Rusty Rudder and recruit the entire bar
to just come back to my house I mean it
was four or five hundred people every
single week that would come to the house
I mean my my liquor bill was probably
around 16 1800 a week in my house in
your house so yeah it was just open bar
everyone's just is like you know yeah
let's go party and so
uh it was a lot of fun I mean I remember
those days where I used to be able to
just uh go all night like you were
saying and as long as I got myself to 12
o'clock the next day I my body would
turn the corner and I'd be like okay I'm
good I'm fine I'm ready to go what's
bring on the next day now it's like put
me to bed and don't bother me for 48
hours like I just I don't have the
capacity to do it anymore I mean age you
know is undefeated right I just can't
defy uh you know you know that chemistry
and so
um I just got into other things you know
for me back then it was just having fun
and being with friends and I really
didn't care about you know you know the
intimate relationships that much and so
I think that you know it just went
through a transition where you know I
was like you know let's look at my age
I'm almost 30 or I'm 30. I don't have
any kids yet I'm not married yet like
it's just kind of you know what's
yeah I want to have a legacy Beyond just
being a race car driver and then I'm
gone right so uh you know it just it's a
steady Evolution that I went through in
my career in a balance that uh you know
I had fun I I don't know that I would
take back a whole lot of it uh but
certainly it's just different now you
know I'm certainly more uh calm now
around my friends I still am very
outgoing and love to have a good time
but it's just very few and far in
between now I mean maybe once a month
I'll go break bus loose or something but
uh even that is is pretty rare when fun
Denny hangs from the rafters literally
it's a really good time I know I know
otherwise Debbie Debbie Denny Debbie
Downer Denny I know you've got it you
got me pegged it's just uh you know
we've hung out enough that like you guys
have always tried to get me to like come
out of my shell and really you know bust
loose but
yeah I don't know it just y'all caught
me a few few years too late
we'll see it every now and again
um like what do you but I mean I feel
like you're kind
of your kind of stuff that exists for a
lot of people in general but especially
you know maybe there's some of this
yo-yo more with Fame what do you think
it is what do you think do you think
it's an age thing or do you think it's
just do you think it's more about
accessibility yeah I mean that's
certainly a big part of it for sure
right I mean uh the the days of like you
know going and meeting someone at a bar
and whatever right and that being a
relationship like that's it's not
existent anymore right it's right at
your fingertips and so I think that that
is that what I'm supposed to be doing
well I mean it just depends but I think
that it's just so different now that
um you know the accessibility that
people have I mean you don't even have
to really go Court anyone anymore face
to face right it's all interactive and
so sometimes I think you lose that human
connection at times and even I'm still
guilty of like you know falling into the
Trap of Technology G and not really
engaging enough in human relations like
I should be what's the difference
between dating back in the 2000s early
2000s when you were mid-2000s when you
started in cup and now I don't know
because I was married and then I've been
in really I was in relationships until I
was 36 or seven or whatever it was so
for me it's like more new to be dating
I'm like oh this is what happens when
you're not interested you kind of just
don't really text anymore and like I
feel like such a dick you know but I'm
like I don't know what I'm supposed to
say like you just kind of Let It Go I
mean I don't know what's the difference
yeah you know what I've really been
guilty of is you know and and that I
went from one relationship to another
you know and you know for me it was I
was with my high school girlfriend for
10 years
um and then when I got kind of full of
myself and and she left me and in 2007 I
think it was
um I just you know kind of went through
a transition where I just wanted to have
fun honestly and I just uh uh I played
around a lot and you know and then I
kind of met you know uh Jordan who's
um who I've been on and off with for 14
years now and
um you know we've kind of mended some
fences and really have uh started to you
know bond that connection again and we
have two kids together I met her uh at
an NBA game she was uh one of the
dancers for the uh the Charlotte Hornets
and I was season ticket holders and of
course uh I'm sitting around you know at
that time I just kind of broken up
uh with my uh high school girlfriend I'm
like oh wow I like her and of course a
friend of ours you know uh reached over
and that's like you know get her
attention try to get her number and they
did and uh that Austin doing your dirty
work no actually it was uh Ron and Jay
Ron and Jay White they're on the
subscribed and they talked to her and uh
it was it was cool because
um you know right from the get-go I was
just like you know ah this is you know I
like I this is the one like I I like her
on a different level than you know all
these girls everybody know she's my girl
everybody knows but I just I just got to
the point where you know I was like you
know I want to have another steady
relationship and so
um you know I don't think that at times
I I made plenty of mistakes along the
way and and even at the beginning that
relationship continued to make uh
mistakes that I shouldn't have and you
know just really needed to kind of find
myself and figure around what I needed
to do to be a better partner because
ultimately the cycle was continuing and
um you know I I have aspirations of
getting married one day I have
aspirations of having uh you know more
kids and so I mean I need you know I wow
I have to do something different you're
already pregnant again no no no no come
on oh definitely no no she's not but you
know I I am 41 like it's yeah I don't
want to be an old dad I want you know
I'd like to have a son I have two great
girls that are amazing but
um you know even in that relationship
that has been on and off for 14 years
um it really it was the first
relationship that really forced me to
kind of look at myself and say if this
relationship isn't what I'm hoping it is
like what what can I do to change it and
what can I do to
um you know change the result can I do
things differently and so I spent some
time away and
um I went to a place that really I felt
like it changed me as a person and and I
just think that that was a a
game-changing moment for me to kind of
be educated about you know what my
family of origin how that plays a factor
in in my values and the things that I'm
into
um and and really was an eye-opening
experience for me to to kind of change
as a as a person to try to be a better
person not only a better person but a
better friend
um a better a better dad all those
things have I think
I'm really proud of you that felt so
good to hear from you and it feels clear
like would you recommend everyone learn
about their parents I mean yeah I mean
what I've learned you know and a lot of
there's so many self-help books that
that you can read about this but you
know I thought it was better for me to
go do a crash course I spent
um a week somewhere and just kind of you
know it was 12 hour days it was really
hard and it was like you know you're
learning to you know not you know get
the kind of Shame out of you and
understand where your values came from
like what did I see as a child that made
me have the values that I have now and
how can I change those values if they're
not you know right and so
um it was very unique you know we we did
some interesting exercises it was
um
draw
um a traumatic your worst memory as a
child with your non-dominant hand like
that was a homework assignment and I'm
just like oh my gosh so I spent hours
drawing this picture
and it was just you know and they said
the reason you do with your non-dominant
hand is you don't judge yourself based
off of you know how you know you expect
yourself to be perfect when you do it
with your dominant hand you expect it to
be a mess when you do it with your
non-dominant so it just lowers your
expectations and makes it so you don't
judge yourself and instead just kind of
let it flow freely do you think doing
all the work that you've done in the
last few years that
you know going back in time you would
have crashed me as many times as you did
uh be honest with you I did not Crush
you at all since stop it things happen
but yeah like three times in a week I
know I know I was a little aggressive
for sure
um but you know usually when I crash my
friends it's only because I'm trying to
help but uh yeah I definitely I'm glad
you just dumped my primary car my backup
and then had to go to another backup for
the Daytona 500. that was what I was
planning too trust me the second one I
think it was during the duel when you
crashed I I hadn't even thought about
the fact that like well she's got a race
for like she's not locked in she has to
get in and so I'm like oh no I'm just
praying the whole time that race is
going on I totally put out of my mind
what my result was going to be that day
I'm like please let her make the race
please let her make the race because
after you crash me yes thanks Mr Bush I
did I know I know uh and so yeah that
was a relief but I knew as soon as I got
out of the car uh I turned around I was
like I saw you stomping down pit Lane
and like well you gotta just take it and
so for me it's it's it is different
because unlike you know if it was a guy
and he grabbed me by I was like you know
I'm like hey let's talk you know but for
you I'm like I got you sit here and take
it sit here and take it
yeah if she kicks you in the balls take
it I I gotta just take this in stride
and so uh there was just there was no
way for me to win in in the public
perception when you were coming after me
I'm like yeah I can't turn her away I
can't argue back with her I just I gotta
be a man here and just take it like a
man
were you scared at all
um yes and no because I I just I knew
that we had had a relationship you know
as friends for a while leading up to
that so I I knew that like you're
yelling at me because you care and
you're yelling at me because you're
comfortable enough around me to voice
your opinion and you know me enough that
I will take it and hear it
so looking back at the scenario you
think I think you told me like you're
too loose I I didn't do anything wrong
you're just too loose let's just be
really honest like tell me like the
serious what really was going on in your
head like is that a fact or was it
something else well I I do think your
cars were too loose yes I I it's so
interesting when I watch some of these
cars like Hendrick cars and stuff and
like how loose they run their cars
during you know speedway races and I'm
like gosh I can't even get the whole way
I'm gonna make you go faster is me
pushing you and if I can't push you then
like you know you're not I'm not gonna
help you I'm just gonna try to dump you
every chance that I get
um I always try to push people that I
feel like are very stable their cars are
stable and I can hit them without them
spinning out but there's just a group of
cars and it was and I think at the time
you might have had a Hendrick Alliance
I'm not really sure but
um yeah it's just they always run their
car so loose that it just it's really
hard to work with them and so uh you
know even to this day it's it's kind of
the same old thing but you know I I
wanted to help but honestly you know it
was just a mistake that that I made and
I've made so many in the course of my
career
um you know making aggressive moves to
you know I've always learned and if you
ever hear Dale Jr say
um you know the way he's found success
on super Speedways is being selfish and
and yeah I'm not the greatest teammate
on on super speedway races I found
success by doing for myself
um and so that this year's Daytona 500 I
committed to pushing my teammates so I'm
thinking in my head I shouldn't be here
this is a spot I don't want to be in I
see cars starting to get riled up and a
wreck is coming and I'm like I should
just bail but I told these guys I would
stick with them and I didn't bail bam I
got crashed and so I just feel like that
type of racing you have to be a little
bit selfish uh but you have to make
aggressive moves and so sometimes that
comes at other people's expense yeah I'm
thank I'm glad thank you for confessing
that you dumped me I I did I did yeah
you know what I look at it like is that
you as a driver we as drivers whatever
we know when we leave no room for air
because we just don't give a [ __ ]
and you don't really care if you hit
someone and that to me feels like a lot
of times the scenario people put
themselves is and is they're just like
I'm leaving I don't care I really don't
care
you know I tried to be I feel like on
the spectrum of super aggressive and
super passive I honestly feel like I'm
on the passive side of my aggression
level I mean my team tells me all the
time like you got to hit that hole you
gotta you gotta you gotta be more
aggressive like we feel like we could
win more races if you're more aggressive
and I'm like I get it but you know to me
there's no art to passing by just
knocking someone out of the way like
that's not I was raised by watching some
of the greatest short track racers like
work over someone and and save their
tires and then blow past them in the
long run and pass them and I was like
that's how I emulated my style and now
of course I've made mistakes along the
way I've wrecked people for sure none
have been intentional except for
sort of one not you no no it's Chase
Elliott 2017 Martinsville no intentions
of wrecking him I was just trying to
knock him out of the way but he's spun
and then you know it tainted my you know
Legacy with the Chase Elliott crowd from
this point on they just can't they can't
get rid of they can't get over it but
it's like you know we all make mistakes
because we're in a business where we run
right up next to each other and we have
to manipulate sometimes that other
person's car to get speed out of ours
and so I feel like I'm I'm kind of on
the passive side but there's always been
I've been doing this for 18 years so if
I have a handful of moments where I've
really crashed someone you know that's
that's not bad
don't be better it's okay
do you think NASCAR should not intervene
with retaliations and crashing because
it always feels like NASCAR gets after
the retaliation and not the initial they
they set a press events when Matt
Kenseth wrecked Joey Logano oh yeah that
was so exciting though it was so
exciting
we heard the crowd right I mean we heard
the crowd going nuts when it happened
for those who don't know he was uh Matt
Kenseth was taken out by Joey Logano and
he needed to get through to the chase by
winning and he was in the lead he took
him out and then the next weekend at
Martinsville nothing happened while he
was up there up in the mix for top three
top five but then once he was a lap down
he waited and came back up on track and
when the green flag dropped at the end
of the race he just freaking dumped Joey
and I for one am joyful about that
because Joey's a jackass on the track he
also is another one that I don't like
probably more than you even
um but he crashed me too and he he's
just a little punk out there look at
just look at his track record just look
at how many people have a beef with him
yeah it's tough because Joey's you know
on that Spectrum I'm talking about he's
all the way on the full end right you
know he is very aggressive and it's been
successful for him but ultimately I mean
sometimes you care about friends
sometimes you don't and and you know
it's not just that but I feel like at
that time yeah Kansas had had enough and
oh yeah I'm just I'm destroying you I'm
making sure you don't make another
corner and NASCAR suspended Matt over
that and their reasoning was is that we
never have stepped in like this before
but Matt wasn't on the lead lap he
slowed down and waited for Joey to come
by and he's just deliberately smashed
him so they said you know it's fair game
as long as you're racing poor position
so we're racing up front
um it's kind of fair game and we saw it
with Ross Chastain and myself earlier
this year I mean we're racing one two
yeah I mean he he's crashed me multiple
times this year and I've always said you
know it will come back around in due
time and and you know I had one
opportunity so far that uh you know lent
itself to me we were battling for the
race win at Pocono and I just left him
zero room and and essentially let him
wreck himself in that scenario and you
know if I'm him I know that okay I've
done this guy wrong he's probably gonna
force me high I probably should check up
he didn't check up and just ran himself
right into the fence but
um it was just NASCAR was okay with that
because we're Racing for a position now
if I had slowed down and just took him
out I think that they have an exception
for that but the problem you need to let
it go and let us continue to police it
because otherwise you know it's just
going to be a bunch of penalties and
that's not gonna be fun for anyone well
the problem I have is that if you're
Racing for position
then you have something on the line and
so it doesn't seem fair like you know if
they took you out you might probably
might not be on the lead lap anymore if
something happened so then they get to
be up there but then you have to wait
until you have something on the line
again yeah and that's [ __ ] I think
you should get the chance I think that
you should just if it all self-policed
itself out there it would all be taken
care of and it would get back to like
rough and rowdy like you know NASCAR
just like Let It Rip I think I love
fights though like I was just so excited
when one was happening and I could hear
one or a red flag would come out and I
heard the crowd I'm like on the radio
I'm like gosh I know there's a fight
what's going on
yeah it's it's different I mean I tried
to a little bit when he wrecked me the
first time at Gateway it you probably
saw highlights of me running around 30
miles an hour swerving back and forth
like slowing him down like he almost got
disqualified from the race for not
making minimum speed I was one lap away
from keeping them from running minimum
speed which would have got him dq'd and
I I knew that I couldn't being a
lockdown at my car was beat up I knew
that I couldn't make contact with him
but I I didn't want him to know that so
I just every time he was around me I
would take a swipe here and there uh
just to voice my anger because I knew
that we weren't going to talk afterwards
and
um it was just uh you know he he
understands where I stand in it
um we've we've raced each other pretty
well since those couple events instances
but
um you know you still you drivers always
keep a scorecard in the back of their
head for sure for sure is he is would he
you call him your base rival right now
it always changes it's not fair like
sometimes you have the one but you're
all depending on how fast your car is
and the year you know you're kind of
racing against different people at
spurts of time yeah I mean that's the
thing is like you know I went to
actually after the first incident I went
to breakfast with Ross and and had a
conversation with us wow I know I you
know I just wanted to kind of hear what
where's the mindset like you know what
happened right and so I listened to him
and I started to realize and we talked
about this values and how you grew up
like my style was that you work someone
over and you you know if you can't work
them over then you sit behind them and
wait on them to burn their tires up and
then they pass them and his honestly was
a lot different his was like he said I
came into this short track Series where
everyone just knocked each other out of
the way and I won on the racetrack and
and I was in the league and someone
knocked me out of the way and I'm like
okay well this is the way that we race
and so that's the way he started doing
it and so
um I just told him that you know listen
I'm not saying my way is right and your
way is wrong but we have to figure out
how to coexist because you know your way
in my way we're likely going to be on
the racetrack around each other a lot
because we're both up front a lot so how
can you you know possibly put it in your
mind that okay you you've done me wrong
and you probably owe me a couple breaks
here and there you don't have to but if
you want to do it again then you have to
know and I told him I have to send a
message back to the field that I'm done
taking it like I you know I've got
wrecked at the at the Indie road course
which lost me the regular season
championship last year I got knocked out
at Martinsville by Alex Bowman
um and and which nearly knocked me out
of the final four he wasn't even in the
playoffs and I says you know I hadn't
done anything to them a lot of the
reasons because I haven't even been
racing around them that much in a
meaningful manner yeah but we are going
to be racing each other this year in a
meaningful Manner and I at some point I
have to send a message back to the field
that I'm done taking [ __ ] and that I am
not going to be [ __ ] with anymore and
he's like I understand you have to do
what you have to do
we hear each other and that was it do
you like doing that
extend the Olive Branch right he did and
so you know the right thing no I mean
like crashing each other I mean like
crashing someone like having to sort of
like send a message to the field that
you can't be messed with I I just I
sucked at it and I didn't love doing it
well even I did a terrible job the first
few times I tried to crash him uh I
always said Ross is one of the toughest
people ever crashed like when he knows
it's coming like he's really tough I
mean he knows how to slow down the right
areas yeah
um but you know it's just
I don't like that I like to concentrate
on you know going out there getting the
best finish that I can and honestly if I
let someone occupy my thoughts in the
middle of a race
um it's not going to optimize my day and
at Pocono trust me when it's 10 laps to
go we're on a restart he's on the
outside I'm on the inside I'm thinking
well I'm gonna win this race and not
only am I going to win I'm going to make
sure he doesn't win because I owed him
one right and so uh it kind of worked
out perfectly right up until our car got
dequeued uh but you know it just uh
things just find their way to work
themselves out we race each other every
single week and it all whatever goes
around comes around eventually yeah the
fines don't really do that much you kind
of end up having to work it out anyway
the probations even like they it's all
just kind of I don't know I have yet to
see what Nascar does with that money
that they make us pay them and I've paid
a couple hundred over the years money
yeah yeah really just to get to the
Bahamas and back yeah
um
so you were talking about teammates
um do you have a favorite
oh
uh I I think about this often and it's
probably Matt Kansas just because yeah
Matt was just such a nice guy and yeah
uh such a fair teammate
um honestly when I think about how fair
are my teammates on track Kyle Busch is
actually one of the most Fair drivers on
the racetrack that I raced around for
you know 15 years that we were teammates
so
um he's always been super respectful
we've had our run-ins of course like
most guys do eventually but I never had
one with Matt he just you know a great
guy he was someone I I don't mean the
age map but he's someone that I looked
up to when I was coming through the
ranks is that he was a quiet guy but he
got the job done and so I really liked
his style of driving and you know who he
was on and off the track yeah what about
a least favorite teammate you really I
really don't have least favorites
um
I get along with all my teammates
um now do I hang out with any of them
off the track no I do not um I never
have uh probably never will I'm just too
closed in for that uh but we all have
really good professional relationships
yeah we we talk to each other when we
need to when it's super important and
when we have information that we need to
share with our teammates I'd say
probably one of the toughest guys and
and I wouldn't put this in the core
category of worst teammates but just the
toughest guy that I really didn't gel
with all that much was maybe Carl
Edwards
um
just because you know he's just a
different guy I mean that doesn't that's
not good or bad he just was a different
guy and so
um I I he wasn't
he was a very approachable person but as
a teammate
um
I don't know I didn't I didn't talk to
him that much what happened to him
anyway I wonder I wonder often Carl
Edwards is doing these days because
after he kind of got wrecked that last
race in the championship at Homestead
and he could have won the championship
and then he'd retired and then it was
just gone poof I think he had enough I
think he was he was going to win the
championship and NASCAR Unfortunately
they called a debris caution that they
shouldn't have
um you know they've that was a wake-up
call I think even for the sanction and
body that like we can't be involving
ourselves in the championship and so he
had the race one they called a caution
um and he had already been very critical
of them calling you know these three
cautions to begin with and when it
affected him and he ended up getting
crashed on the next restart I think he
just had enough that's enough he also
thought it was something about like his
brain or like injuries it was like
rumors I haven't heard any different
right but I think that in in my mind
this is my opinion that he had he had
just he had acquired enough money he had
made enough money he was happy with what
he was doing
um but he just didn't need this sport
anymore you know he realized that if I
can't win this thing organically and
someone is just going to take it away
from me
um why am I why am I here why am I
working so hard for the sport that is
willing to just take it right for my
grasp right at the end which is it was a
tough deal it was certainly not good for
Carl and that was the last we saw
that's right why do people not like Kyle
Busch in your opinion
uh abrasive I think he's just abrasive
um he's he's uh interesting to talk to
for sure
um you know I always say that the Bush
Brothers they they have a lot of
conspiracy theorists in them I think
that they they really believe you know
people are out to get them all the time
which I don't believe is the case and
um so they always just have that chip on
their shoulder right and and it's so I
think that Kyle's just got that
personality that really uh you know you
you're either are going to like him
because he goes out there and he
performs and he's a badass driver or you
hate him because you don't like his
attitude out of the race car you know no
one no one is before I know his attitude
outside of the car is pretty piss-poor
yeah no one it's entertaining because
you know you're gonna get something but
he is like
yeah no one hates Kyle on the racetrack
like no one's like he's a dirty driver
he doesn't you know he's not good where
everyone loves Kyle and what he brings
to our sport on the racetrack it's just
off the racetrack
um that that has been challenging uh for
Kyle and I think that honestly you know
this is why he's you know making
probably another team move right is that
you know that
it's he's not you know the relationship
with with Hendrick and then with Gibbs
isn't didn't end because of his On Track
Performance it just you know it really
started to take its toll off the
racetrack I think for the race teams and
um you know it was tough but you know I
have a ton of respect for Kyle and and I
I hope he really does well at RCR and
really can bring that program back to
Championship caliber uh like it has in
the past but
um you know I I I admit every word that
I said in in my goodbyes to Kyle on on
Twitter was true that he's certainly
made me a better race car driver he's
he's a good person he's got a good Soul
um you know people just don't always see
that because you know he because he
doesn't show it he's not the fan
friendly guy that's gonna sit there and
stop and sign autographs for 20 minutes
as he walks out of the tunnel he's just
going from point A to point B and if he
if you catch him on the way you catch
him if you don't I don't he's not going
to take any extra time to to you know
satisfy you
yeah what about what did you entertain
the idea of
asking about being on your team
I did
um did you I did yeah I um I wanted to
keep them in the Toyota family because
ultimately I believe that he was better
within our organization than he was
outside and I'd rather race with him
than against them
so I I did
um speak with Kyle and we got you know
we got some conversations going
you know the tough part for our
organization was that um you know we
couldn't guarantee any long-term
contract I think we could offer
something short term uh but with the
unknowns of uh Kurt's status uh for next
year and the following year I I knew
that I just needed a placeholder there
just in case and you know I told Kyle
that like Kyle I need you to just to get
in the door and then let me work on
making it long term I can make this long
term let me work on selling you if I
can't sell you No One's Gonna sell you
so I I really wish he he we could have
worked something out but he needed
long-term stability and and I think that
he got that with RCR and I think that he
saw it as a lateral move
um you know he saw how competitive the
Tyler heretic has been in the eight car
this year and I think he sees that as a
chance for him to win right away and to
get a long-term deal to you know put
numbers on the table that he was
comfortable with for long term but it's
unfortunate for us to lose him but you
know I yes I went after Kyle because I'm
I admire his talent and and I feel like
um if I would if I could have you know
wrapped my arm around him and maybe his
brother wrapped his arm around him and
said okay here's here's our culture
here's how we do things if you can buy
into that then let's let's talk
long-term 12 months from now but he's
like no I'm not wearing J's just done no
I I think he was into it but it's just
you have you know he was going to take
the guaranteed bet you know and the
guaranteed debt was taking something
long-term versus I just didn't he didn't
want to go through this process again as
well yeah you know if we if we didn't
have a spot for him in 2024 or we didn't
want to make it long term he didn't want
to go through this whole free agency all
over again I think it did take its toll
on him how old is he he's 37 or 38 years
old so he's got a six-year Runway there
that you feel like he could be you know
fairly competitive and when you race
this in championships so it was a it was
a long enough Runway but for us it just
I couldn't without knowing what NASCAR's
business model will be years from now I
I can't just lock myself in and say okay
I'm gonna be three cars in 2023 or 2024
no matter what there's still more I need
to see that before that I pull that
trigger what um what do you think NASCAR
needs to do to
make it more valuable for the sponsors
and kind of get to a place and it might
not even be NASCAR's job I don't know I
don't I like what needs to happen I mean
there's undeniably a ton of big names
that have left in the last
four to eight years yeah I I think that
the value that the teams get are very
good one thing that we noticed right
away in the sponsors that we brought in
is said wow the access in NASCAR is
unlike any other you know no we can't go
into the locker rooms of another Sport
and hang out with the drivers or the the
players 20 minutes before they go get in
a car but they can do that in NASCAR
right and so
um the access is what makes us unique
and what really puts us I think above
any other sport as far as the value uh I
know with FedEx I've been with them for
18 years and that's just been an unheard
relationship that that has lasted that
long right and so it's because they see
value in the program
um it's they're able to host potential
you know uh Partners or customers
um or maybe you know special VIP
customers that have been with their
company for many years many employees
one of the big things why they got into
this sport was a rallying try from their
employees saying we wanted a NASCAR car
to root for on Sundays and at the time
you know the the brown car was out there
and they're like go beat that car right
and so uh it was important to them to
have a team that was represented that
that beat that car and uh luckily I was
able to get that done for him but you
know for us it's it's difficult because
we are sponsor driven our team model and
our team business is sponsor driven so
uh the bulk of our Revenue has to come
from sponsors because we don't get the
revenue from the league
um you know the share in which we we
hope to have so we have to go to these
sponsors and ask for a large number to
just get to zero right well what does
that attorney to do what needs to change
ultimately it's it's to share the
revenue differently um you know we share
in 25 percent of TV money Revenue
um where most League share in 40 to 50
percent of all revenue so that's a big
big difference from what we are
um so I think that that would allow us
to not have to charge our sponsors so
much to get us to zero
um we could then it's a full budget
what's a full budget in in Cup right now
like about 20 million to field a good a
very good car that runs up front
um and and that's that's pretty firm
that's without a driver as well not
every race is that considering every
race yeah that's every race all the
exhibitions and everything so you know
for me personally I think that it's
how can we shift the model a little bit
to where we don't rely on sponsors to do
this
um so much and how can we I honestly we
if we cut our price point in half for
our sponsors then we probably will have
quadruple the interest right but it is
pretty expensive and the next part of it
though is that there's so many different
options right it's they used to not sell
patches on on NBA players uniforms
anymore so now I think I read an article
where there's 3 000 different
opportunities for a business to sponsor
in sports where back in the day right
when when it was the Heyday of
sponsorship in NASCAR you know if you
wanted if you wanted to be you know you
couldn't stream you didn't see it on
Twitter if you wanted to be on a car you
had to be on a race car right and so
there's just so many options now that it
that it's gotten diluted and it really
forces us to kind of fight and scrounge
to to find the partners to put it all
together
um but ultimately I think you know down
the road if the if the revenue changes
it puts us such in a better spot to then
we we helped build the sport I mean look
at F1 right Liberty Media came in they
bought it and they said okay we're gonna
share 50 50 with everyone and they
realize pretty quickly when the teams
are healthy they're the ones that are
out there activating so we're putting up
nice chalets and great VIP areas those
are the things that we need to be doing
in our sport uh that the teams right now
just can't afford to do
um
yeah
do you think you got in at just the
right time as an owner or
are you like uh right or wrong one of
the two it's either one or the other for
sure
right you know ultimately you know we we
came into this as a you know me and
Michael it was on a whim that that we
started this
um it happened during covet I was
sitting at home for eight weeks and I
realized pretty quickly that there's no
way I can play golf every day nor do I
want to so what am I gonna do myself I
think of that one-man tennis match that
you got you have on the putting greens
that's right one that's yeah you
remember that so I just said what am I
going to do I knew I wanted to start a
business I didn't know what it was I
actually approached Toyota about buying
some dealerships
um was that going to be my end goal when
I was done racing but I realized pretty
quickly that racing is what I love I
love giving back to the sport and making
I want to make the sport better when I
leave than it is when I got here and do
is that really in your heart or are you
just saying this well it is because it
has so much potential it really really
really does but at times you know I I've
said this before it's very difficult to
tell dinosaurs to eat differently and
and so how can you get some of these
people that have got so stuck in their
ways for so many decades to change the
way they think to make this sport bigger
and better and you have to open up the
ideas and what you have to
um to make change and and NASCAR is
starting to do that they have a really
good group in charge right now that are
starting to really see the light and and
starting to see that you know we have to
invest in different areas we need to
invest in our infrastructure there's no
way we should ever go to our Racetrack
and not have cell service like that's
just absolutely crazy right I mean we
want people to share those those great
moments on their Instagram burning man
does not have cell service just so you
know well that's fine because you
probably don't want to see that stuff on
the internet but but you wanna if you
want to grow the sport you have have to
make sure that you have connectivity a
great infrastructure people don't want
to sit on 95 degree bleachers for four
hours anymore they expect cushion seats
with a concierge service they can go to
an app and have food brought to them
that's the way they expect it nowadays
that's just the way the people are
everything we have we expect to be
better and faster and nicer than it was
last year and I think that it takes a
lot of investment infrastructure to make
that happen so I think that we're
starting to see race tracks really spend
a lot
on their infrastructure which is very
good because you can get people to erase
one time but if they don't have a great
time and they gotta wait in a concession
line for 45 minutes and they don't have
any Waters they ain't coming back and
that's the problem is we just kind of
took advantage of the old race fan for
too long
true I mean I waited 10 hours to go
a few miles on a dirt road to get to the
pavement at Burning Man 10 hours and I
was the next day I was like man I can't
wait to go back next year wow yeah but
that's that's got to make it fun that's
an acquired event right and I think that
you don't have to have all these Lush
reached and everything we have places in
our schedule for those sweetheart
racetracks North Wilkesboro we're
bringing back Martinsville those are the
sweetheart 60 year old race tracks that
camp campers that's fine all that is fun
you don't have to have great facilities
there that's a place for it but when we
go to Texas when we go to Las Vegas
wherever it might be these huge markets
if you want to bring in big customers
and and sponsors they're going to expect
a lot for for what they what they spend
and you better have the amenities that
they're used to what's what's Michael
say about that Michael Jordan for those
who don't know yeah I mean he's just
been a a great partner how did you talk
him into this I know he's into racing
but he used to be into bikes right he
did he had he owned a motorcycle team
and so just local back it all started
during covet and obviously I'm like well
what am I going to do and immediately I
asked David Wilson like is there any
interest in me owning a race team you
know jjr was losing uh LFR coveted took
its toll on a race team that was a
Toyota team I'm like can I pick up the
pieces of that team and kind of bring it
in and start a new team and and wow are
you drunk when you thought of this idea
I that's what Joe asked me he's like are
you crazy uh you're making all the money
now why do you want to go spend it but
um I just thought that you know I wanted
to have my say and and honestly I got
down to Richard Petty Motorsports and
that was a team that I was looking to
buy a minority stake in
um but ultimately I found that I wasn't
going to get the control that I needed
the autonomy to really run it the way
that I thought it needed to be be run
and so I'm like yeah this isn't the
right fit for me either and Bubba
Wallace was a free agent and he had some
sponsorship with him and I'm like you
know
what how can I put all this together
because Bubba used to be part of the
Toyota Racing family and even with Joe
gets racing how can I put all these
pieces of the puzzle back together and
so
actually a speculative article came out
and it said
that Denny Hamlin and Michael Jordan
were looking to purchase a minority
stake in Richard Petty Mercer which was
absolutely not true I never even talked
to Jordan about this at all and so
um a lot of it started from the rumors
from the ownership at RPM at the time
they had other celebrity people that
were looking to buy a minority stake in
there and people just assumed that that
celebrity was Michael Jordan because I
was friends with him absolutely not true
I took this article the headline and I
sent it to Michael and I'm like let's
just see what he says here so I sent it
to him and he says wow that's obviously
not true it's fake news but if you want
to make it real news let me know I'm
like
okay
how do I respond to this now never
forget I was on the ninth hole at the
golf course on my second shot and I got
so fluttered that I left my ball sitting
there I went to the green and they're
like dude you didn't even hit your shot
and I'm like oh I gotta go back and get
my ball because I'm like how do I
respond to this and so he says well are
you gonna be a team owner or not and I
says
I'm thinking about it why he says well
if you are and you want a partner let me
know and I says when can you meet he's
like so I says all right I'll be there
in two days I got my team at Pro support
management to essentially type up a
business plan here's here's here's how
it's gonna go people in need they worked
day and night to get me this this
business plan to give to him and I gave
it to him and I says you know here's the
plan he's like all right well looks good
to me but it's got to get vetted so he
gave it to his business people they
spent about a month getting NASCAR 101
education on all this first they asked
like are you kidding me this business
model is terrible I'm like I know but it
could get better it's possible that it
could get better these are the best or
the worst time in the whole wide world
to start that's right we will know we
will know and you guys like to gamble
that's correct and so uh you know listen
for us we you know the the we decided to
pull the trigger a month later he's as
I'm in and we started a race team which
has now been 18 months ago so it's it's
crazy how it all started we've won you
know three races in in LA in the year
and three quarters that we've been in
the sport which is unbelievable are you
surprised by that
because it's so hard
let alone when you just start a team
this is not easy beating Kendrick
Motorsports and Joe Gibbs Racing had
that have been around for decades is
hard and like in in Ford versus Ferrari
when they make it look like it's people
were like oh my gosh Is that real I'm
like it's harder than what they made it
look like there's more politics than
what they make it look like I was like
they just built a car to go win at Le
Mans like that does not happen I know
especially how impressive yeah it's just
been crazy because you know it is hard
to come in here and win and so for us to
have three wins already it's just been
amazing
um we're on a trajectory I told everyone
this this is a five-year plan I told
Michael Curtis my whole team this is a
five-year plan to be a championship
contending organization
um that is a real timeline now we are
only in year
1.8 or so right so this is still a
building process but you know we have
have some big plans on the horizon that
we're working on we're kind of waiting
to see where this model goes before we
pull the trigger on them but ultimately
I feel like we are going to be a team
that wins races on a regular basis every
single year uh you know at least a year
or two from now like I you know we're
already competitive we're already listen
in the final you know we already punched
our ticket in the owners Championship to
the next round uh with Bubba Wallace so
it's just uh really been amazing the run
that we've been on and bringing on Kurt
Busch was just one of the best things we
ever did I love Kurt I think Kurt's a
great guy and he's very helpful he's a
very helpful teammate as well so I'm
sure he's been helping in that category
well I actually I'm wondering what is
going on with him
um but first first before I ask that
question
um are you more surprised to be winning
races we'll have won a race in your
first year and have three wins at this
point in time with that with not even
being completed with the second season
or are you more surprised that it's
Bubba do you more surprise the bubble
one
a couple times oh that is a great
question
I would say
that I'm more surprised with Baba and I
thought he was very good but I didn't
realize the potential that he has now I
it was a bumpy first 10 months trust me
with Bobby it was like you know
trying to get him to okay here but
here's my process in which I get ready
for races here's the data that I look at
here's what I think you need to be
studying
and it's tough because
I expect him to have the same work ethic
as me but like I can't control him right
I can't all I can do is say here's
here's the formula that works for me
hopefully it can work for you but I
realized quickly that like he needs to
be his own person he needs to do the
things that he he sees correctly and I'm
really really proud of like how he has
progressed as a NASCAR driver like the
strides he has taken just in the last 10
months has been unbelievable he's taken
himself he's done to do that I admit
he's taking himself from a mid-pack guy
to someone that runs
chronically in the top 10 every single
week now and so what do you think like
it's just been great to watch because
he's now seeing the results of the work
that he's putting in and so it's always
tough because if you don't see results
from work that you put in it's easy to
quit right away right it's like I'm not
here for the long game I'm here for the
the immediate gratification and I think
that you know we trying to walk them him
through this process that here's what
it's going to take for you to be better
down the road and here's what you need
to be keeping notes on for next time and
I think he started to do that and
started to see great results and now I
think it works like me now he's feeding
off of it and and give me more give me
more because he's starting to see
results and see his true potential wow
well good job in teaching him but it
sounds like he just started to work
harder yeah I think he he really started
to buy into the the things that we asked
him to do uh the things that we asked
him to study and you know ultimately you
have to want it right I mean this is a
that everyone is is so good and I've
realized in my older age that I have to
I don't have the natural talent that
most of these good drivers have I can I
just work hard that's just a fact I feel
like I work hard and I work on my craft
really hard and you know I'm open to new
things if I need to drive things
differently fine then then whatever I
need to do to to get better as a driver
I never have stopped learning as a
driver even 18 years in and so
um I think that that's what we're trying
to instill into our drivers is for them
to be the best that they can be and
we're starting to see it
okay let me give you a scenario
so you race for
three more years
you get
eight more wins
but you don't win a championship or this
year you win a championship
and you're done you're done after this
Championship when you win in after you
win it or in three years you'll never
won a championship
and you'll have retired and you'll but
you'll have like eight more wins which
is a couple more each year which you're
pretty good for
yeah I mean for me I know I want to get
to 60. I want to get to 60 where are you
at 48.
um you're not there so you won't make
60.
yeah you'll get eight more you'll Race
for three more years but you won't have
a championship
ah this is tough but I'm gonna take more
wins I'm gonna take getting to 60 with
no Championship you can't get to 60
though you get eight more that's it
but if you're saying I win a
championship this year and I'm at 48
wins and I'm done I would rather have 60
wins and no Championship three years
from now just simply because I value the
wins more so uh and I value the
Championships less than what I do have
in in years past because the way they
crown the champion is just a lot
different than it used to be it's just
one race now and it's like
I won 60 of those so what's the big deal
right we've had Champions that have won
like 10 races so yeah 60 is means like
you've had a long career and it's been
successful throughout your career to me
that means more
um do I win a championship absolutely I
mean am I tired of hearing about it yes
but it doesn't Define me I mean people
know all my competitors know when I hit
the racetrack they're gonna have to beat
me to go win the race this weekend and
so that's all I care about is is having
the respect for my peers that I am one
of the best regardless of whatever I
have in that stat column of a
championship
so it's safe to say that your first goal
is getting to those 60 wins in your
career and your second goal is a
championship yeah it is I mean you know
for me people always ask well how does
it work if you
if you race a car and you have a team
that you race against how is that not a
conflict and I always say well
ultimately I want to win for me more
than I want them to win for me like I
get more gratification if I'm the one
winning versus someone winning for me so
my perfect scenario every week is me win
and then finish second and third like
that's perfect for me
um when when bubble one I finished
second honestly I was I was in a funk
that day I was just in a bad mood
because I felt like our team lost out on
winning a race and like you know I had
to shape myself and say wait a minute
we're just one as a team like this is
huge and and so awesome for Bubba and so
it took me a few hours to get over that
but yeah it's just
it's so different and I just feel like
I love what I do I don't see any
I don't see a timeline for me stopping
uh as long as I stay competitive I'll
never go out there and just know that I
can't win any given week if if I if I
hit the racetrack and I'm 43 years old
and I'm like I need to I'm just open for
a top ten today I'm [ __ ] done I will
not do it just to collect the paycheck
and go out there and make laps well I
mean that kind of leads to an
interesting conversation little
conversation about what what what what
what is it that puts a an athlete into
retirement like why like explain the
situation like how does it happen why
does it happen what ends up making the
decision why does it always seem so
sudden like on unpack what it ends up
getting a driver to retirement because
yeah drivers is different than I think
other sports
um yeah sometimes you get forced out I
mean other sports that happens as well
like they believe in the young guy and
they don't have enough Runway with you
right uh in NASCAR I think that
I think it's largely Financial driven
because eventually the team puts enough
compression on you to say like man is it
do I want to keep doing this schedule
for keep taking less less less less like
no I don't I want to end on a good note
I always I sit on the Dale Jr download
I'm like yeah I want to win my last race
and you brought that up like would you
win the championship and be done I said
I wanted to win my last race and so
whatever it takes for me to win my last
race
um that's that's what I want to do and I
never want to let my skill set
deteriorate where I don't have a chance
to do that so
um I think you know it's amazing to see
people like Mark Martin and Kevin
Harvick's I think Kevin Harvick's 46 or
47 and he's won two races this year now
I would say is he as sharp as he was
five years ago
no but he's he is a guy that works hard
he's got a great team and a great crew
chief so they continue to win so I think
that's what fuels him but I think if he
was 38 40 years old he'd probably win 10
races every year like he has you know
just a few years ago but I think that
eventually our our Reaction Time
declines and you know as well as I do
you have to have really good reaction
time your hand-eye coordination your
your brain says to do something in your
your hands and your feet don't react in
the same time as it used to and
ultimately the financially it just
doesn't make sense to do it anymore and
I always said to Joe Gibbs Racing
the minute you think I am an I am a
liability to your bottom line and not an
asset let me know because that that will
be the message to Me That You Don't See
the value in me no longer as more than
just a driver right I bring an alliance
I you know have a great relationship
with FedEx that that has been strong you
know I bring a lot to the competition
side
right now they still see me as an asset
when they look at what they spend what
they spend on Denny Hamlin is an asset
and they still believe that
there will be a time down the road where
they're like
uh can we get that off of our books like
because we believe that he's not
bringing in what he was uh years from
now whether it be performance or
whatever all right well then what's on
what's on your list like there's gotta
be stuff you're thinking I for sure
thought this like of things that I
wanted to do when I was done what's on
the list other than Burning Man Jimmy
Johnson did go to Burning Man for a few
days one year Jimmy and Jeff and those
guys they they've been trout more than I
do I'm I'm really jealous of how
outgoing they are and trying to help you
I know I know I know um bring Jordan
everybody knows she's your girl let's go
I know it I feel like
every time I start to think about it I'm
like well I'll just do that when I'm
retired because it's it's five years out
it's six years out whatever like I'll
still be fine okay but what are those
things it's it's traveling like I want
to go to Australia and I've never been I
haven't been like
across the pond anywhere like I just
been here you've been to Europe no never
been so I just want to get out and try
some different things my kids are at the
age they're really starting to get into
theater especially Taylor uh Molly will
be getting into something you know a few
years from now that like I don't want to
miss so I think that's probably
some of the reason guys retire as well
is the family right you can't miss look
at Tom Brady you can't miss some of
these important moments right and so uh
I hate that I don't get to see some of
the soccer games that that Taylor plays
and
um she's always like you know why are
you always working and even during the
week right it's like hey I gotta go
sorry I got to go to a meeting I got to
go to the shop I gotta go here and she's
like why do you have to do you should
just quit racing I'm like Taylor I can't
do that that's how I've we afford to do
all this stuff that we do and you have
the toys that you have it's because I
work hard and so you're like Daddy has a
full basketball court in his house okay
Daddy listen there's a lot to pay for it
nothing pisses me off than hearing my
kids say they're bored I'm like
in this house yeah with a bowling alley
basketball court you know you got
go-karts you can go ride like all this
stuff drives me crazy but uh I try my
best to keep them as humble as I can and
not spoil them but I I love seeing the
joy when like you know I can make a
difference and do do something nice for
them so you want to travel
I want to travel a little bit and I
really want to concentrate on building
the race team I mean if I'm going to
build a new a championship continuing
organization five years I need to
designate blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah I love
working but I love working I mean I
don't do vacations well I don't turn my
brain I know I should so that is the
challenge for me is that I'm a good
three-day vacation guy that's at that
point then I'm like okay what am I
missing what meeting am I missing I'm
sure they need an answer on something I
know I just like to be him I need to go
back to therapy for that one I know I
gotta let go I I get it I gotta live in
the moment I I need to decompress and
relax listen it's taking a toll on my
sleeping everything so it's just I
really I know that I still gotta grow as
a person
um but I'm still in that process I'm
never
stuck in my ways and I'm more educated
now that I'm able to change uh than I
ever have and so I'll continue to change
every year from this point forward well
Denny 2.0 has come a long way and Denny
3.0 when Denny can go on a week-long
vacation without getting ants in his
pants will be another version 3.0 and
you'll get there you'll totally get that
support I mean I don't do anything I get
sweatpants on right now underneath all
this
might walk my dogs you know you'll get
there I promise all right well thank you
good luck appreciate it thanks for
having me on thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today I hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the Subscribe
button